in the far southwest of Westeros at the
mouth of the river honey wine lies the
great stone city of Old Town it is home
to the Citadel where men and boys from
throughout the kingdoms come to receive
their training as maesters maesters play
an integral role in Westeros a society
serving as scholars healers and advisors
to the nobility of the Seven Kingdoms
this venerable
order of learnin men dedicate their
lives to serving the realm and us warned
to occupy a neutral position when it
comes to power and politics upon
completing his training of the Citadel
and taking his vows a maester renounces
his family name and takes a vow of
celibacy he is assigned to a castle or
keep and duty-bound to serve as its
counsellor and healer even if control of
the castle changes hands and maces
allegiance is to the realm not to any
one family his badge of office is a
great chain forged from links of
different metals which he wears around
his neck it is a reminder of his role as
a servant of the realm and is never to
be removed a maester forges his chain
with study and each link represents the
mastery of a different kind of learning
for instance the Silberling signifies
mastery of the medicinal arts a golden
link represents the study of money and
accounting an iron link indicates
knowledge of Warcraft Raven ray is an
especially important skill for a maester
as it is he who breeds trains and
maintains carrier Ravens for the
delivering of messages throughout the
land
there are some masters who have earned a
link forged of Valyrian steel this
signifies knowledge of the higher
mysteries commonly known as magic only
one maester in a hundred possesses such
a link as this feel of study is frowned
upon by many in the order it is possible
magic may have existed for a time not
long ago but most consider the higher
mysteries to be long gone from this
world service as a maester is a noble
calling
one of vital importance to a prosperous
realm it is little wonder there are some
who refer to the order as the Knights of
the mind